[Music]
welcome back
so today we are going to derive the
one-dimensional heat equation
and it might sound like a pretty simple
thing to do but this is a big step to
get practice at deriving partial
differential equations to encode physics
basic physics that we know like
conservation of thermal energy
in a few lectures i'll derive the 2d
heat equation and we'll get
the heat equation and laplace's equation
for the steady state distribution
and this is the same kind of idea of how
you derive the continuity equation navy
or stokes equation
really how we encode physics in general
is that we kind of keep track of all of
the
you know some quantity like thermal
energy and we derive a conservation law
based pde for that so i'm going to jump
right in i'm super excited this is one
of my kind of favorites
okay so we're going to consider the
temperature distribution u of x and t in
a thin metal rod so let's actually draw
like a little um you know you can just
kind of imagine this is a wire or a
little piece of you know metal that you
can pick up at the hardware store
and u of x and t
is the temperature distribution
literally the temperature at every point
in x so x is how far i am along this
this thin metal rod
u is the temperature distribution and
it's evolving in time
okay so let's just draw
x
and the boundary conditions are going to
be 0
and l x equals 0 and x equals l
and u of x and t is this temperature
distribution that's changing in space
and in time
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to use common sense
that there's like a conservation of
thermal energy in this thin metal rod
and we're going to derive a partial
differential equation that has to be
true for that conservation to be
satisfied
now i'm going to assume a couple of
things here i'm going to assume for
example that this is an insulated rod so
we're going to put kind of a styrofoam
sheath around it
and maybe i will you know fix the
temperature at the boundary conditions
or insulate the boundary conditions
and i'll start with some initial
temperature distribution
u of x at time 0 so that would be my
initial condition and what we eventually
want to do is you know we're going to
derive that partial differential
equation but then we want to solve that
pde for the distribution u of x and t
everywhere in space at later times t i
want to know what the temperature
distribution will be like in the future
and this is important for lots of uh
applications right predicting the
thermal distribution in an object is a
critical
capability when we design engineering
systems like a space shuttle re-entering
the earth's atmosphere we better be able
to tell how the temperature distribution
on the surface changes in space and in
time okay
uh good so let's jump in um we are yeah
essentially going to like i said use
common sense
uh to derive this partial differential
equation
so let's start doing this
and i want to write this out in words
for first
so the rate of change
of heat energy in time
the rate
of change
of heat
energy
in time
is going to equal is going to equal
the
heat flux through the boundary at every
point in space if i take uh this is
actually going to be a really important
thing
we're going to take a little segment
of
this and we're going to zoom into that
segment we're going to zoom in
to a little segment here
okay
if we zoom into that little segment then
there will be heat flux through the
boundary into the next element and if
it's insulated it won't go
out to space but it'll only go to its
neighboring little elements to the left
or to the right of it
so the rate of change of heat energy in
this uh this rod at in time is going to
equal the only way it can change
is if heat energy fluxes out through
conduction to its neighbors
so heat flux
heat flux through the boundary
through the boundary
to its neighbors
plus any heat generated at a point in
space plus any uh heat
generated heat energy generated
energy generated
uh in kind of x and t and at any point
in space or in time
and so for example maybe i have a fancy
way of heating up a little local patch
of this and putting in heat energy maybe
i can inject heat energy with a blow
torch at this point
and create you know this kind of
heat spike here that would be
adding heat energy like this or maybe my
thin metal rod is not actually made of
you know
copper or something like that maybe it's
made of plutonium and it's actually
generating you know heat radiate heat
through some atomic process maybe
there's some some atomic process
generating heat energy at each of these
local segments
now the cool thing about this is that
this
basic
this is just a basic statement
that if i insulate this object
the only way that the total heat energy
the total thermal energy of the system
can change in time
is through heat flux through the
boundaries or if i zoom into a little
patch through its neighbors
and if there is heat energy generated at
each of these local pieces uh in time
either through you know external forcing
or through uh you know molecular atomic
processes like like fission
and so this is just a very very general
statement of the conservation of thermal
energy this is basically always true
even for exotic materials this is going
to be true even if my
boundary was not insulated then i could
have had heat energy lost through
radiation this would be uh i would be
able to include radiation effects in
here as well thermal effects nuclear
effects radiation effects
and it's true integrated over the entire
uh domain but it's also true when i zoom
into a teeny tiny little local segment
of the domain and that's going to be a
really important point
so now i'm going to write each of these
three terms in math okay
and maybe i will do this in
pink here
so the total heat energy
is given by uh our temperature
u
of x and t
but the a particular uh pro material
let's say this is copper or lead or
whatever material this is
has some physical properties that tell
me how much heat energy there is at a
given temperature
and at a given you know mass or density
so it's not just u of x and t i have to
multiply this by
rho of x the density
and by c of x the specific heat so i'm
going to write these down otherwise i'll
forget so this is the density
this is the specific
heat kind of the you know the heat
capacity
of the uh of the object
and this whole thing here
is the heat energy
the heat energy in some little kind of
infinitesimal
segment of this this would be the heat
energy in that little infinitesimal
segment you could multiply this by a
delta x if you really want okay
and what we're saying is that the time
rate of change of this the ddt of this
quantity ddt uh really this is a partial
derivative with respect to time partial
ddt
of the heat energy
can only there can only be a change in
heat energy due to flux through the
boundaries or source or sink terms heat
energy generated or lost at points
at points in space
good okay
[Music]
and so this is going to equal so let's
keep the color scheme here
this is going to equal heat flux
through the boundary at each point i'm
going to write this as a minus
partial q
partial x i haven't told you what q is
this is a
heat flux quantity that is related to
the temperature i'm going to derive it
over here
plus
these sourcing terms q
of x and t
okay
this is literally the only way that the
heat energy can change in a little
segment is by heat flux uh
through the boundaries to its neighbors
or a source or sync term maybe this q is
radiating energy or maybe there's an
atomic process generating heat energy or
maybe you're hitting this point with a
blow torch that all lives inside this
forcing function q
okay um
good and i want to also label these this
is the heat flux
heat flux through boundary and this is
my
my kind of source
term and we call it a source but it can
also be a sink you can also be bleeding
energy off through radiation and things
like that
by emitting light
okay fantastic so
i want to tell you what this q is i
haven't defined this q yet and it's
really important so i haven't told you
why i have minus partial q partial x as
the heat flux
that's what i want to derive now and
then we'll go back and we'll simplify
this into a nice pde that we can work
with using
fourier's
law of heat conduction
good and i'll of course at the end like
i normally try to do i will kind of zoom
out and re-summarize all of these pieces
but again remember all we're trying to
do is write down conservation of heat
energy and figure out where what could
change the heat energy in time and in
space
and now i'm zooming into the heat flux
term into this term here because this is
a little bit confusing
so let's say i have a little teeny
segment of this a little infinitesimal
delta x segment
and so i have um
what i'm going to call this q
of x and t
is called the heat flux this is equal to
this is the heat
flux
from left to right
and i have to say from left to right
uh because that convention of it going
from left to right is what allows me to
get this sign correct so i have to
actually pick that heat flux is defined
positive heat flux goes from left to
right so this
gains heat if heat fluxes in from the
left and it loses heat if it flows out
to the right okay
good
and so what i want to do
this has the units of thermal energy
thermal energy
per
time thermal energy per time that's what
this heat flux is
and i am going to derive we will figure
out what this q is using uh
fourier's law of heat conduction and
maybe i'll just i'll tell you what it is
i don't want to like
uh
kind of beat around the bush this is
equal to some minus
kappa partial u
uh partial x
okay so i'll i'll come back to this in a
minute so this is uh what it actually
equals
and this is kind of intuitive this this
uh fits our intuition that if i have two
little segments next to each other one
that's very hot and one that's very cold
so that there is a gradient of the
temperature in space that this is
partial u partial x meaning there is a
change of temperature in the x direction
if i have that partial u partial x
then i expect there to be a large heat
flux at that location okay so the heat
flux at a location x
is directly proportional to the gradient
of the temperature at that point x so if
i have a really steep temperature
gradient really really hot on one side
really really cold on the other this is
a big number and i get a lot of heat
flux this is common sense okay
but it was you know this took a long
time to be derived this is a major
result
so this q of x and t
um
what i want to do is actually like write
this down so we have q
kind of coming in here this is q
um at x and t q
of x and t
and there's also some little
infinitesimal heat flux out
this is q at x plus delta
x
uh and time
and so if these two are equal to each
other if the if the
if the amount of heat flux in is equal
to the heat flux out then this term is
zero there's no rate of change of heat
energy in this little volume
and so that kind of tells you why now if
there is a gradient in this heat flux if
i have more heat flux coming in than
going out then this should be a net
positive rate of change of heat energy
in this volume
if i have more heat flux leaving than
entering i should have a net rate of
change decrease in the total heat energy
in this volume
and so it's always a pain for me to get
this sign right
but basically what we are computing
is this partial q
partial x the gradient of this q
heat flux tells me roughly if heat is on
average entering or leaving this
this little infinitesimal volume
and so this is like the limit
as delta x goes to 0
of q of
x and t
minus q of x plus delta x and t divided
by delta
x and that's
minus
so essentially what this says is that if
i have more q coming in
and then i have q leaving
then i have this kind of uh then
oh i always get the signs
mixed up let me try to do this really
really carefully what i'm trying to do
is i'm trying to figure out why this is
a minus sign and try to convince myself
that this is actually correct so let me
just slow down a minute
if i have a
negative gradient of q
what that means is that q is bigger
coming in than going out q is bigger
than medium then small that is a
negative gradient of q that is a
negative partial q partial x
and if i have a negative gradient of q
that means i have more heat energy this
one's bigger than this one i have more
heat energy entering than leaving
so if i have a negative gradient of q
with respect to x i have a positive
a positive
rate of change of heat energy in that
little volume
so when partial q partial x is negative
this should be positive and that's why i
have that little negative sign out there
so this does fit with the convention
that if i have a negative gradient of
heat
flux q that should have an increase in
the heat energy and that little point
x
okay
now
this fourier law of
heat conduction is really important
that's how we right now what we have is
a partial differential equation in terms
of u
and q and little q and what i want is to
write this all as a little partial
differential equation of u the
temperature so i want to relate my heat
flux directly to the temperature and
that's what the fourier law of heat
conduction allows us to do
so maybe i'll just give you a tiny
little aside this is where fourier
enters and this is not for the last time
so fourier
has
a treatise on heat conduction it's a
beautiful book you can still read it
today translate it and it actually gives
his thought process as he is deriving
these equations and analyzing these
equations it's quite interesting
and actually the heat equation is why
fourier developed the fourier transform
in the first place so we'll see that
later
and so fourier made these three
observations he did experiments or he
collected the information from other
people's experiments newton's
experiments and others experiments
that there is no heat flux
when the temperature is constant
so if the temperature in this rod is
constant from you know at a point x if
it's the same temperature to the left
and to the right there will be no heat
flux that's the first observation
the second observation is that heat
energy flows from high temperature to
low temperatures so if i have a high
temperature on the left and a low
temperature on the right i will get a
net flux of heat energy into this low
temperature region so heat flows from
high temperature to low temperature
that's also observed
that's the second property and the third
property
is that there is more heat flux when
there is a larger temperature
difference if i butt up two little
pieces of metal and they are 10 degrees
different
that will
change conduct heat less fast and if
there's a 100 degrees difference the
bigger the temperature difference the
faster the heat flux
and so essentially if you put all three
of those together you get fourier's law
of heat conduction which is this
expression here the heat flux from left
to right the the thermal energy flow in
time
is equal to this minus kappa
times partial u over partial x the
gradient of u with respect to space the
derivative of u in space
um
this kappa is really a kappa of x just
like my specific heat and my density i
explicitly made these functions of x
because i might have a weird material
where it's copper here and then it's
lead and then it's a mixture of copper
and lead
these properties can change in space
okay good
and so this fourier's law of heat
conduction allows us now to write this
pde in the following way
okay
and you'll notice that c and rho are not
functions of time so i can pull this
partial derivative so it's hitting u
and so what i have is i have c of x
times rho of x
times partial u
partial t
equals
now partial q of partial x the partial
of q with respect to x
because q is partial u partial x maybe
i'll just write this out
negative d dx
of negative kappa partial u partial x
is just positive kappa
partial squared u partial x squared
so this equals kappa
um partial squared u
partial x squared good
plus
my source term
and i've dropped you know u is a
function of x and t big q is a function
of x and t i have actually you'll notice
here i i cheated for
expediency's sake i am assuming that
this kappa is a constant this
kind of this is the rate of thermal
conduction kind of how much
heat is conducted the conductivity
and i have assumed that that is a
constant otherwise when i take partial
partial x i'd actually have to do a
chain rule and i'd get a slightly more
complicated expression
here and so i've kind of simplified my
life
and if you simplify and basically say
that
you know c
rho
and kappa are constant
in space
then you get this nice expression
that partial u partial t
equals kappa over c rho
partial squared u partial uh x squared
plus this constant you know 1 over c rho
times my forcing function
and that is
essentially i'm going to box this i
think we did it
this is the heat equation this is the
diffusion part of the heat equation this
is the diffusion constant this is that
positive constant
uh alpha squared we talked about before
that just you know tells me how heat is
diffusing
and this is any forcing term you know if
i hit this thing with a blow torch if
there are
atomic you know fission processes
causing heat energy to create
this is the forcing term here
and so this is pretty cool this is the
actual
full on heat equation for a constant
material
uh 1d thin metal rod
okay good so in future lectures what i'm
going to do is i'm going to generalize
this for 2d 3d nd we're going to derive
the n-dimensional heat equation for you
know a
a three-dimensional object like the
earth or something like that
and it will be
a partial differential equation where
now this will be the laplacian of u okay
instead of just a second derivative with
respect to x it'll be the laplacian of u
in fact i'll just write down you know
we'll essentially get u sub t equals
alpha squared
laplacian
of you in the absence of forcing terms
so that's one thing we'll do we will
also look at how do you actually solve
for the heat distribution given you know
initial conditions and boundary
conditions and source terms
we will solve for the steady state heat
equation so if in steady state this
partial u partial t is zero this partial
u partial t is zero
and so in steady state
in steady state we have
the laplacian of u
equals zero or if there's forcing
minus q
okay
uh
minus q good
so that's all uh coming up to analyze
these heat equations but again just
re-summarizing re-summarizing
the way we derived this partial
differential equation was by common
sense we know that in any material in a
one-dimensional metal rod of material
the total rate of change of heat energy
and time
has to
come from two places there can be heat
flux through the boundaries heat
conduction let's call this conduction
through its boundaries to its neighbors
and then other forms of heat generation
or loss for example through radiation or
fission or a blow torch or external
heating or whatever
and this common sense conservation of
heat energy allows us to mathematically
write down this partial differential
equation
now we had to use things we knew like
this conservation of thermal energy we
assumed that was true we also used all
of the experiments that fourier
conglomerated into his law of heat
conduction so that we could get this
diffusion term here but the process is
actually relatively straightforward you
take a conservation law
and some know-how and some vector
calculus and you derive a partial
differential equation
all right so more on this later
soon thank you